this morning in our pushing-the-limit
series we'll look at how the Marine
Corps is Danai zhing with basic
technology you could find online
John Crawford is in Alexandria Virginia
to show us the boot camp that is putting
a 21st century spin on the Marines
slogan of improvise adapt and overcome
Jan good morning well good morning so I
mean this may not look like the kind of
place where you'd be training Marines
but in this warehouse a new generation
of Marines is preparing for modern
warfare some of the same tools that the
enemy is using they're welding even
building robots and drones like he said
some of that stuff you can buy online
and rid up in the field this is not a
theater of war these Marines expected to
be fighting in but this so-called sumo
robot competition is training them to
confront a modern enemy this is
innovation boot camp a five-day hands-on
training course designed to teach
Marines how to use the latest in cheap
but effective technology Internet is
your friend too so these are all tools
at your disposal awesome fantastic guys
veteran Brad Halsey created the program
the Marine Corps is amazing in the fact
that they are very depth at solving
problems on the battlefield with
whatever they have and so why not equip
them with today's technology like
welding laser cutting and 3d printing
the goal and power Marines in the field
to solve their own problems a graduate
3d printed a wrench that would have
taken six months to replace uses a CAD
program Kat it up did a couple
iterations printed it and then it
totally worked
Marines also learn basic coding with
kits you can buy for less than a hundred
bucks this is a Arduino robot Arduino is
just a basic design program for guys
like me who are big game Staff Sergeant
John so logic is an explosive ordnance
disposal technician I've got a little
tiny room to get into I just need a peek
in there
okay well if I have an Arduino kit I can
do that on my own program it right there
exactly what I need for that situation
and learning about this gives you the
ability to be more efficient yes and do
things more on the fly yes the
battlefield is moving towards electronic
warfare not knowing this is gonna put
you behind behind the enemy terrorist
groups like Isis have weaponized basic
drones even use them to drop small bombs
this is a commercial off-the-shelf the
ground these Marines are learning how to
modify them to level the battlefield
well you know they always talk about the
Marines how you guys you know can like
jerry-rigged everything and you have to
improvise you have to innovate I mean
that's kind of what you're doing yeah
absolutely improvise adapt and overcome
and this is definitely just us doing
what we do best a massive earthquake has
hit the garden absolutely catastrophic
for the final challenge of the week the
Marines are given a simulated disaster
relief mission this is you're a drop
there's nothing else coming they'll need
to find solutions using the technology
they've learned you have to drive your
robot into the room assess where the
four bodies are after you find all four
fabio drone operators
one team hits a road bump a camera
they've trained to survey the room goes
down captain Matthew our debt is with
the Marine Corps Systems Command things
go wrong how do you react to it three
amps Matt's and what did you learn this
week that you can apply to it on the
spot in the moment in a high-stress
situation this is the most important
part of this training right here this
actually it kind of didn't work is
important exactly and as you can see
it's now up and running call this marine
MacGyver's is that if they're really
like MacGyver yes ma'am that's exactly
it is marine MacGyver training using
circuitry microcontrollers 3d printing
the computer-aided design and that's the
future of warfare yes ma'am it is we're
looking for the tune of marine
MacGyver's even with technology there's
still a use for duct tape in the Murray
duct tape and hot glue
now Brad Halsey and his team are rolling
out this program around the world
they've already set up a Technology
Center at a Marine base in Kuwait and
right after our visit here they went off
to Okinawa Japan for two weeks of
innovation boot camp there beyond us and
that is awesome to watch I love that
innovation boot camp no hand-to-hand
combat right just learning the skills
for the future they say with duct tape
though you can do anything I love that
the characterization of marine MacGyver
yeah duct tape and hot glue a lot of
places